Major, major win. A huge federal
decision has just come out in Texas that
actually appears to apply nationwide
in favor of the Second Amendment. If you
are a member of the Firearms Policy
Coalition or the Second Amendment
Foundation, dealing with ready for this,
carrying guns into federal post offices.
This is a huge deal, folks. A big win
for the Second Amendment and frankly a
loss for Pam Bondi and the Department of
Justice. Uh we'll break it all down when
we come right back.
>> [music]
>> Hey folks, I'm Mark Smith, host of The
Four Boxes Diner podcast American Gun
Owner Constitutional Attorney. Member of
the United States Supreme Court bar and
proud to say the top voice of the Second
Amendment in America. Thank you both
2025 and 2026 Gunny Awards. All right,
this is a fantastic bit of news, folks.
This has been a big fight and it's
turned out golden, turned out roses,
whatever metaphor you want to use in
favor of the Second Amendment. Down
there in the United States District
Court for the Northern District of Texas
in front of Judge Reed O'Connor, there
was a huge fight over whether or not the
Second Amendment prevented the
government from barring American
citizens from carrying guns as a general
matter into post offices in the United
States. And Judge Reed O'Connor in a big
decision, relying in part as I recall on
the decision by Judge Katherine Mizelle
out of Florida, found that indeed there
is no basis
to ban to ban or no constitutional
permission if you will to allow
government to ban Americans from
carrying guns in the post offices with
only two very narrow exceptions, which
we'll get to in a moment.
But overall, there is no historical
tradition of restricting the ability of
Americans to carry their guns in public,
which is of course what Bruen said, you
have a right to bear arms in public,
i.e. carry guns in public for the
purposes of self-defense and in case of
confrontation.
And there is no basis for the federal
government to say that post offices are
somehow sensitive places that you can
ban guns on that property.
Now, Judge Reed O'Connor went on and
this is the big fight and this is the
big win today.
In addition to finding that it was
unconstitutional for the federal
government to ban guns in post offices
with two narrow exceptions, we'll get to
in a second, pretty narrow exceptions.
Um there was also a fight as to who
benefited from this ruling. Remember how
I've explained to you
at this channel we don't just train you
about substantive stuff. We don't just
talk to you about the meaning of the
Second Amendment. What did Joseph Story
say? What did James Madison think? We
don't just train you about the substance
of the law. What is the law? We also
spend a lot of time talking about the
process by which cases move through the
system.
That's why we talk about en banc review.
We talk about motions to dismiss,
motions for summary judgment. We talk
about standing and the like because all
these procedural things, if you mess
them up, means that you do not get to
win for your Second Amendment
substantive rights. Well, this is a big
deal, folks, and illustrates my point.
The fight, the big fight that we in the
Second Amendment community just won
hugely was this.
Who benefits from the court's decision
that says
the federal government cannot ban
firearms in post offices. Who benefits
from that?
Well, the Trump administration argued
that the only people that could benefit
from this were the specific plaintiffs
that sued.
And that the members of these
organizations
um
were the only ones who conceivably could
benefit.
Well, guess what? The court rejected
that argument in a big way. Judge Reed
O'Connor said that the beneficiaries of
this ruling, meaning those individuals
who are able to carry guns into post
offices consistent with this order,
consistent with the law,
are not just current members
of the Second Amendment Foundation and
current members of the Firearms Policy
Coalition, but also, ready for this,
drum roll please,
also future members of these
organizations.
This is a big deal, folks, because the
court
rejected arguments by the Trump Bondi
Department of Justice,
said that under long-standing Supreme
Court precedent,
you continue to have what is known as
associational standing, associational
standing, sometimes referred to as the
associational standing doctrine.
And you're like, Mark, why do I need to
learn about the associational standing
doctrine for crying out loud? And the
answer is because it is the difference
between going to prison and not
potentially.
Because under the associational standing
doctrine, it says that if you are a
member of an organization that wins a
case that benefits from, let's say,
injunctive relief, i.e. an injunction,
then you're protected by that
injunction.
So, for example,
if you are a member of the Second
Amendment Foundation today, if you're a
member of the Firearms Policy Coalition
today,
at least as I read this order, you
should check with those organizations
specifically, make sure I got this
right. Right? You want to talk to them
if you're a member of these groups or
you want to become a member, you got to
talk to them directly and have them
confirm what I'm saying, but I think I'm
right. I think I'm right, but you should
confirm it with the groups that are
actually litigating these cases if you
worry about your personal situation,
whether or not you personally can carry
a gun into your post office or to
particular post office or to particular
post office that are not covered by this
order. Okay? So, with that disclaimer
out, basically associational standing
says this, if you are a member of an
organization, if you're a member of the
National Association for the Advancement
of Colored People, the NAACP,
or you're a member of the Second
Amendment Foundation,
you're a member of the NRA,
you're a member of the Gun Owners of
America,
you're a member of the Firearms Policy
Coalition, whatever it is you're a
member of,
if that organization that you're a
member of sues in federal court and wins
and gets an injunction
on behalf of itself and its members,
you're protected. You're covered by that
injunction. So, here the big fight
that's been going on is the scope of the
relief. Who was going to benefit from
this huge win for the Second Amendment
against the federal government that was
trying to enforce the ban on guns in
post offices?
Well, the judge today, and I'll link to
this order if I if I think I can link to
this order,
um
found that indeed all the members of the
Firearms Policy Coalition, Second
Amendment Foundation, and future members
are going to be covered and protected by
this order
once they're members.
And if they join in the future, they
will also be protected as long as this
order continues in effect.
Here is specifically what Judge Reed
O'Connor said in ruling for the Second
Amendment rights claimants over the
arguments by the federal government that
were basically saying that the scope of
the relief should be much more narrow.
Check it out. Based on the foregoing,
the court grants in part defendants'
motion and clarifies its order and final
judgment as follows. The permanent the
permanent injunction as set forth in the
court's order, ECF number 35, and the
final judgment, ECF number 36, applies
to plaintiffs, and listen carefully,
folks, applies to plaintiffs and to all
present
and future
members
of Firearms Policy Coalition and Second
Amendment Foundation.
Amazing. It's amazing. It's correct, by
the way. 100% correct.
And I want to step back and give you
some context here.
This doctrine of associational standing
that says that if you're a member of an
organization and the organization sues
in federal court and wins a case and
gets injunctive relief for the
organization and its members, it was
always basic black letter law going back
many decades, Supreme Court precedent
very clear, in fact, even written about
at the time of the founding in various
contexts. Okay? Very clear that if an
association is sued on behalf of its
members, if the association wins the
case, its members
benefit from the injunction even if the
members themselves don't like show up
and appear in court because they are
implicitly being represented by they're
implicitly in the case through an
organization which presumably, this
makes a lot of common sense, right?
Think about it. Presumably everyone that
joins a particular organization has
similar interests and common goals. So,
if you join a Second Amendment
organization, presumably the reason why
you're joining a Second Amendment
organization is you have an interest in
the Second Amendment. You have an
interest in guns. You have an interest
in the freedom and the right to keep and
bear arms, right? So, it makes sense if
an organization representing members
that have these common interests and
desires and goals, right? And hopes,
guess what? It makes sense that if your
organization representing all those
interested people win a case that they
as members should benefit from that
court victory. And that is basically
what Judge Reed O'Connor said. And this
is not crazy in the least. This is
long-standing American law. This is
exactly what happened in the so-called
Civil Rights era where the
African-American groups like the NAACP
would bring these lawsuits in the South
arguing over segregation and whatnot and
they the NAACP would win its case and
the members of the NAACP would get the
benefit of the desegregated school or
the bus station or whatever it happened
to be in those cases, they benefited.
So, really all that's going on here is
we in the Second Amendment community are
taking those long-standing precedents
that organizations like the NAACP used
in the 1950s and 1960s, and we're taking
all those bricks, we're taking all those
precedents, and we're applying it to
vindicate the most fundamental civil
right of them all, fundamental American
liberty of them all, the right to keep
and bear arms that actually finds itself
in the text of the Bill of Rights. And
what I just said is basically
articulated by Judge Reed O'Connor.
Here's what he writes in his order
today. The doctrine of associational
standing recognizes that the primary
reason people join an organization is
often to create an effective vehicle for
vindicating interests that they share
with others. And suits by associations
on behalf of its members are different
from class action lawsuits. In
plaintiff's complaint, Firearms Policy
Coalition and the Second Amendment
Foundation clearly indicated that they
were bringing suit on behalf of their
members stating, quote, Firearms Policy
Coalition brings this action on behalf
of its members, and SAF brings this
action on behalf of its members.
In crafting its injunction, the court
here is mindful of the government's
previous argument that any injunctive
relief should be tailored to the
plaintiffs in this case. But the
government did not argue, and the court
did not interpret this to mean that only
individual members of FPC and SAF who
had membership at a certain date should
be included in the court's injunction.
Rather, the court interpreted this as
arguing against a nationwide injunction,
which the court did not issue.
And that's exactly right. The doctrine
of associational standing has been
around forever. And we'll at the end of
this video, I'll give you a brief
distinction with the Caetano case
dealing with nationwide injunctions why
I think the Trump administration is
rightfully worried about some of these
issues, not so much when it comes to the
Second Amendment, but they're clearly
fearful that some, you know,
whack-a-doodle federal district court
judge that hates Trump in Boston or
Chicago or San Francisco is going to use
anything they can to thwart the Trump
agenda to do, among other things, kick
out all the uh illegal immigrants that
never should have come in the first
place. But I digress. With that said,
the court specifically addresses here in
ruling for the Second Amendment that
it's not doing anything to violate the
Supreme Court precedent of Caetano,
which dealt with nationwide injunctions.
Here's what Judge O'Connor had to write
about that. In crafting this injunction,
the court was mindful of the Supreme
Court's ruling in Caetano. But the court
intended its injunction to inure to the
benefit of those members of the
association actually injured. This
includes future members. Here what I
just said. This includes future members.
Not including future members could cause
FPC and Second Amendment Foundation's
injunction relief, injunctive relief, to
disappear due to attrition or death of
their members, or impose a significant
burden on the organizations to track
which members qualified for injunctive
relief and which do not. And as another
court has explained, could result in
continuous litigation and be a waste of
digital resources, as well as the time
and resources of the litigants. Exactly
right. So, let's just step back and
think about this from a common sense
point of view. So, today, in the year of
our Lord 2026, the Firearms Policy
Coalition has members.
The Second Amendment Foundation has
members. They've just won this huge
case. They've got this injunctive
relief. Let's play out a hypothetical
where
it does not cover future members that
join these organizations tomorrow or
next month or next year. Let's play that
out hypothetically, okay?
At some point,
as [snorts] time waits for no man,
all the members of FPC and all the
members of the Second Amendment
Foundation will die out. Or they'll quit
or whatever.
At which point, the lawsuit would have
to be brought again
on behalf of new members seeking the
same relief. Or, in a more basic way, if
you limited this injunction to members
as of today,
well, let's say you go out, you're not a
member of the FPC, you're not a member
of the Second Amendment Foundation, and
like 3 months from now,
you join.
You would have to, if you limited, if
the court limited the protection of this
injunction to current members, then a
member that joined the organizations
like 6 months from now would have to go
out and bring another lawsuit
and waste the court's time and waste the
resources of the organization. So, to
avoid that judicial inefficiency, the
court here correctly, and this is
consistent with long-standing law, this
is not new law, he's just applying old
Supreme Court precedent, the court went
on and said, that's why the court said
it applies also to future members that
join these groups in the future,
tomorrow, next month, next year.
Otherwise, it'd be totally inefficient
and silly and would just give rise to
ongoing continuous litigation, which is
in no one's interest cuz you never get
finality and you waste a lot of time and
money. Okay, there's just two additional
points that I want you to know about.
First of all, now, again, there are
exceptions to this if you're going to a
post office, I think, on a military
base. I think if you're going to a post
office like in the basement of Congress
or or some other place attached to a
federal building where there's other
federal functions, I don't think that
that applies there. Again,
if you want to be a member of these
organizations, if you want to follow the
law, if you want to get this right, you
need to reach out to the Second
Amendment Foundation and the Firearms
Policy Coalition and find out exactly
what you should do and find out exactly
what you should not do because they're
going to be advised, presumably, by
attorneys who can in turn advise the
members. So, don't take anything I'm
saying here as legal advice, you never
should do that. You should check with
your own lawyers, and in this case, I
would check with these organizations
immediately to find out the full scope
of what you can do and what you can't
do. Although I think I'm generally right
here, you should always double-check
with them because they're going to have
the best information, give you the best
advice, and the best guidance. So, you
can't take my word for it. I'm just
giving you the big picture. Now, with
that said, I want to introduce something
that you need to be aware of, and this
is I don't know the answer to. And
again, the organizations might know the
answer to that, and that's this.
When you're the beneficiary of an
injunction involving a potential crime,
you got to be sensitive to this issue.
So, let's say you're a member of the
organization and you go into a post
office.
And
can the government arrest you?
I think the answer is possibly yes. And
what do I mean by that?
There's two ways to interpret these kind
of preemption and injunctions. One is,
is it a preemptive injunction? One is,
is it an affirmative defense to an
indictment? So, what do I mean by that?
So, if you walk into a post office and
they say you have a gun in a post
office,
they could say, "Okay, are you a And you
say, "Look, I'm a member of these
organizations, benefit I benefit from
this injunction. You can't stop me."
If that is viewed as preempting
the charge, then you'd be able to do
this, you get a you'd be able to avoid
the arrest, presumably. But the some
post offices or police or law
enforcement might take the position
that, "Well,
you're in the post office with a gun,
I'm going to arrest you,
and then you get to go to court, and as
an affirmative defense
to the charge of carrying a gun in a
post office,
you get to demonstrate that you are a
member at the time you were in the post
office with the gun of FPC or SAF, and
then you get off at that point. So, I
don't know how if this is going to work
as like um if you're confronted with the
police, if this will be like viewed as a
preemption to an arrest, or will this be
viewed as like an affirmative defense to
a post-arrest situation? I just don't
know. And again, this is why I'm urging
you all, if you're a member of these
groups, you want to be a member of these
groups, to reach out to them and get
guidance from them cuz they should be
able to walk you through this stuff in
detail. I can flag the issues, I can
talk about the big picture, but the
specific particular legal advice or
advice that you may need, you should get
from the horse's mouth and not from a
YouTube video. The last thing is, I
think the federal government has
appealed this, so, you know, we'll see
what happens. There's going to be a lot
going on here as this goes all the way
to the Supreme Court. But for the
moment, very exciting news, very good
news. Congratulations to Firearms Policy
Coalition and to the Second Amendment
Foundation and to all of its members.
And again, if you're interested in
benefiting from this injunction, I
strongly urge you to reach out to these
organizations and get guidance as to
what to do and what not to do cuz we
certainly don't want anyone getting into
trouble with the law anywhere in this
great country. And you've always got to
be careful cuz there's a lot of bad
actors out there that want nothing more
than to arrest law-abiding American gun
owners that support Donald Trump, if you
know what I'm saying. I think you get
the point. All right, folks, hope you
enjoyed today's video. Make sure you
follow me on X @ForBoxesAndArrows. Don't
forget to subscribe both to YouTube and
Rumble. I'll talk to you again [bell]
real soon here at
Table 2A.
>> [music]